so um i mean like you have this meteor
meteoric rise uh you've got a a
supplement blank brand you got a
clothing brand you've got the glorious
hounds of house of gains podcast
um all of this kind of came to a
grinding halt for you when you had a
health issue
a couple months ago i i don't know the
exact date so i'm wondering if maybe we
can
you know spend some time around that but
i mean what what was it that
created the health issue do they ever
get to the bottom of it i mean i'm sure
a lot of your haters are just going to
come at you with oh it's all because all
the steroids and all that sort of stuff
yeah of course um no
like you said everything was clicking on
all cylinders everything was going great
my merch was moving the supplements i
don't own
steel supplements that's owned by
someone else but i'm one of their
top people i guess you could say a lot
of people think i own the company but i
really don't
um everything was was clicking podcast
was going great and then
uh tail end of february of this year
just a couple months ago i started
crapping blood
and you know when when you live the
lifestyle that i live and
although i'm not a competitive
bodybuilder i live
the bodybuilding lifestyle i do the
supplements i do the super supplements
i'm not ashamed to say it
and throughout the years i've crap blood
before but it usually went away after
about a week
this was not going away and it was
getting worse and worse and worse and it
turned out where i was making
like 30 to 40 bowel movements a day of
just straight blood
and you know i'm a i'm a dude i'm a guy
i'm like it's going to go away i ain't
going to a doctor
yeah i got it it just drinks some more
water man exactly
exactly so um it got to the point where
it was so bad where
i mean i couldn't walk my lower back
like
everything was shutting down on me and
my wife rushed me to the er
they did all the tests they diagnosed me
with ulcerative colitis
that was on march 11th um and
i was in the hospital being treated
aggressively uh with
all the steroids not the good kind but
the kind that they give you in the
hospital and
ivs i had four ports in each arm of them
just shoveling all all this medicine in
me
um and i was in the hospital for about a
week and a half
and then my colon perforated kind of
like when your appendix
burst my colon burst and
i needed emergency surgery on march 24th
they removed four and a half feet of my
large intestines
um and after that surgery
everything went downhill my kidneys were
failing my
lungs were failing my heart was failing
my liver was failing
every specialist in the hospital were
like i was their number one patient it
came to the point where the
the um what do you call the the
religious guy that comes into the
hospital
yeah the priest including your last
right sort of thing yeah
he would come in and visit me and i'm
like listen do you know something i
don't because
i really don't want to talk to you right
now i'm not really that religious of a
person but
um yeah so it was really scary and then
things started to turn around and then
on april 1st
my colon perforated again they left a
little piece of coal they left like
10 inches of my colon so hopefully i
could get
because i have a bag a colostomy bag on
my stomach now where i take a poop
and um uh hopefully i could get this
reversed
uh in a couple months but they let they
had to leave a certain amount of colon
in order for that reversal to be
successful
so um with that little piece that was
still there
on april 1st just a couple weeks after
my first a week actually after my first
surgery
that piece burst again so i was in all
kind of bad shape i was in the hospital
for two months
so um how much of that
like was a product or a or like
was gear a catalyst to any of that
because i know that um they've done a
lot of studies on steroids and i've been
on
on trt since i was 43 so i don't mind
talking about it
um i mean i've been down to mexico where
everything you get over the counter is
like you you don't need a prescription
for [ __ ] so it's like i'm gonna have
some deca and have some of that i'm
gonna have some of that and you just
kind of pile it all together
right you know you have a good time with
it you know while you're down there but
um there's a lot of studies that
that show like that you know prolonged
use of um
you know higher dosages of gear will
create problems for certain organs
more specifically stuff around kidneys
and like urination and
prostates and all that but i've never
heard of anybody having
like colon failure because of uh
testosterone and other gear right so
can you talk about that a little bit i
mean do you have any insight
since yeah i mean they they tested me
the the way that you get what i get
is two ways it's either bacteria or
it's autoimmune they tested me for the
nine million different types of bacteria
that it could have been from
food or just whatever i ingested or put
in my body
they ruled that out 100 they said you
have
the autoimmune version of um ulcerative
colitis
and they're still not 100 convinced that
ulcerative colitis is going to be the
final
diagnosis there's still a possibility
that i have crohn's disease which is
like a sister disease to ulcerative
colitis um
and if i do have crohn's then this bag
that's on my stomach right now is going
to be with me forever and that's going
to be horrible so
i'm praying that it's uh that it's
ulcerative colitis
um but they said it was going to come
out no matter what it had nothing to do
with
with the gear nothing to do with the
supplements nothing to do with the food
i was eating
it was just it was always going to
happen and it just picked its time and
came out and i i've noticed i've talked
about this in
other interviews i've noticed my stomach
changing
over probably the last three years where
i loved hot food i loved buffalo wings i
loved all this all that
my stomach wasn't having it anymore
within five
ten minutes of me having anything spicy
or or
hot um i was in the bathroom and i was
like whoa this is weird
yeah and it didn't look like for many of
the pictures that i saw that you've
posted
um you know on social that you had
anything that would have like you know
distended your abdomen
or had like fatty liver disease or
anything because you're still pretty
like trim in your waist area right
uh well yeah i was um but what happened
when i went
yeah so before i went to the hospital
everything was good there were no
problems
um but when i got out of the hospital i
went in i went into the hospital at 209
pounds
i came out of the hospital at 138 pounds
wow
so i lost how tall are you
um five five nine and a half five
ten that's that's a ton of weight man oh
yeah yeah
and that was all muscle mass too i bet
right
oh every everything gone and that just
goes to show you what like you know
elevated levels of cortisol and stress
will do your body like it just eats your
[ __ ] muscle mass so quickly
yeah 100 that that's every every bit of
muscle i even asked the surgeon
uh i was like why is it that every ounce
of muscle that i ever put on my body
just
disappeared and she gave me some you
know uh
professional explanation for it and it
made sense at the time i couldn't even
regurgitate it but
um you know yeah and so that being so
light
and and frail um and i posted videos
and pictures of you know how i looked
when i got out of the hospital and
the the the way that my brain worked i
just wanted to put on the weight as soon
as possible so i was in every drive
through i was in wendy's i was in sonic
mcdonald's just eating ice cream and
burgers and
anything to put on the weight and i have
gained 25 of those pounds back i'm in
like the low 160s right now
um but it's not good weight
it's it's all my stomach and my i got a
i got belly fat that's hanging over my
belt line right now it's
horrible but we'll get back why are you
eating that stuff though like why aren't
you going more you know like
you know leafy greens and like organic
grass-fed meat and stuff like that like
why do the drive-through
you know process [ __ ] because i knew
that was going to be the easiest way to
put on a lot of weight
as soon as possible and i really didn't
care where it went or how it looked
but the one thing with having this this
bag on my stomach you have to stay away
from
roughage and stuff so i can't eat salads
or any kind of
spinach or lettuce or anything like that
because it backs up the uh
the ileostomy that i have wow so that's
a big change in your lifestyle eh
oh yeah because i mean i was i was eat i
was i was a bro i was eating grilled
chicken and
and broccoli and sweet potatoes and you
know all this good healthy food
um and now you know i just didn't have
the appetite
for it i was like i don't want grilled
chicken and broccoli i want a hamburger
and french fries let's get this weight
back on
you